what is Up Guys in today's video I'm
going to be using GE tracker to help me
find items that I can create and flip
for more money for example I'm going to
start off with the tridon of the Seas
and then I'm going to look at some more
items and figure it out but as you can
see the tridon of the Seas I wrote down
how much it will cost to make it all on
the bottom so 550k 250k 50k 25k 55k all
that adds up to 930 that's how much it
costs to make it if you buy all the
supplies and put it together and you can
sell it for 974k so I'm going to start
off by buying all the items to create
the tridon of the full and then I'm
going to go ahead and sell it and see
how much profit we make and then I'm
going to go ahead and move on to another
item that you can do all right now we
will start buying the
supplies so if you didn't know the
tridon it's 2,500
charges and we'll buy that first and
that's what the full one is um we're
going to buy this for just over what it
says so 55100 to see if it sells and
then you also need to charge it with
death runes chaos runes and fire runes
and then
coins um we'll buy we'll just buy these
for 220 and then I'm going to buy 2,500
cuz that's how many you need for one
charge and then you also need 2500 chaos
runes and we'll buy those for
100 and then you also need fire runes
all right one sec let me look up how
many you need real quick all right sorry
I had to look up how many you needed cuz
I was kind of confused but you need five
per charge so you need 12,500 of them
okay those instant sold everything sold
right away pretty much the chaos runes
actually sold for Less because they
instant sold um we're going to go ahead
and buy this for
more we'll see if we can buy it for
let's try
58k okay it didn't sell right away so
we'll go ahead and wait a little bit I
might change the price I'm not sure yet
all right so I did change the price to
60k and an instant bot so here we go all
right let's go ahead and charge it okay
25 200
charges now I will do the math of how
much it costs all right so I did the
math I added it all up and I got 914k
995 I'm just now realizing I forgot to
do the coin so I got to add 25k after I
sell this but we'll put it in for 970k
cuz I kind of want to sell it right away
so we'll see what it sells for okay
literally 2 seconds later it sold so
970k with the coins added in to that
914k that's about a 30k profit now we
will move on to the next item okay the
next item I'm going to use I looked on G
tracker I went to the item sets and
crafting section and I noticed that the
guthan's armor set is selling for 235k
profit I went ahead and checked on o on
OS buddy and then the profit that I
found it's a 116k 87 profit
so um I'll go ahead and get all my money
again and I'm going to buy the guthans
[Music]
items I'm G to buy this I'm going to buy
them each for just a little bit over
probably about 2k over so
1750 um plate
body I'll buy it for a few K Over
635 and the reason why I'm buying them
for over the price it says to buy them
for is cuz I noticed that there's a 116k
profit so it's okay if I lose a couple K
here and there cuz I'm going to be
making it
back and now the war spear
all right so I'll go ahead and wait for
those to sell I also noticed that the
arum set is going for a good profit so
I'm going to go ahead and do that I
found that it's a 64k
profit buy the hood for um we'll buy it
a little bit
over so already bought okay that's good
news if they're already buying and the
plate body I saw bought all right we'll
buy the staff for a little bit over
hopefully these all instant cell okay
sweet they're all instant selling it
looks
like ARS R Top
okay that's looking like oh okay that's
all
two now the
[Music]
top okay we'll go ahead and sell that
okay sweet they all sold actually so
that's
good okay this one bought for 10K under
this one bought for 2K under what I
bought it for this one bought for 2K
under oh wow this one bought for 30k 38k
under that's actually insane so I'll go
ahead and put pack this that means I'm
going to make even more money than I
thought I was making so I'll go ahead
and do the math on this and then I'll be
back okay so I did the math and it cost
me
2,535 786 to buy this now I will just
sell it for a better price than what I
bought it for so if I sell it for this
I'm going to make about 105k so now I
will go ahead and find some more items
while I'm waiting all right back on G
tracker I found that the Unholy book
page set is selling for a good profit
I'm going to go ahead and collect this
so I can buy all four zamrock pages so
I'm going to buy the first one
for 530 and it's 125k profit if I can
make the book so that's why I'm buying
these for over the price Samurai
page all right so I'm buying them for
about 5k over just to see if they sold
the second one did not instant sell
let's see the third one
[Music]
does all right it did okay hopefully the
fourth one does
[Music]
all right it did not but I will be back
when they sell all right everything sold
thankfully now I'll go ahead and collect
them and I'll do the math to see how
much I spent all right so I spent
1,633 830 so now I will make this into a
set and then I just have to sell it for
over that
price and also the arum set did sell so
that was an easy 105k profit we'll sell
this for about a 30k profit we'll see if
it
sells all right now I will go ahead and
look for more items on G tracker and I'm
going to go ahead and board these
because I don't think these are going to
buy so I'm just going to go ahead and
dump
this um yeah we'll sell for like 1K
more okay oh I actually I think I made
profit on that but now we will buy the
armadel pages I found that I get a 65k
profit on
these if I make them into the book of
law so I'm going to go ahead and do
that armadel
page I'm going to buy them all for about
2k maybe 3K over and see if they
[Music]
sell
336k all right oh that one sld never
mind the first one did not sell but the
second one did let's see if this one
sells it's better if you can instant buy
them even if you're buying them for over
the price cuz you want to get the quick
profits right away because the prices do
fluctuate so you got to be
careful ignore that update so 237k oh
wait whoops
247k all right so two of them did
instant sell so that's good and O and
they bought for a lot underneath or
under the price so I'm just going to go
ahead and abort these and buy them for a
lot more because I just saved about 40K
from those two so I I have about 40 more
K to spend okay so I bought the second
and the fourth I don't want to
accidentally buy the same page that
would not be good okay second and
fourth okay
205k actually we'll buy for 210 cuz I
have more money oh okay thank
[Music]
gosh now we'll buy the third
one um we'll just buy it for a lot more
just see if it sells okay that one did
sell too sweet okay so they bought for
less than I put the price in so that's
good so I'll go ahead and do the math on
this and then it okay so I went ahead
and did the math and it was 986k to buy
all these so now I will sell the book of
law I'm making about 80k on this I'll
sell it for about 9k less okay so they
haven't sold but I will make a lot of
profit from these and keep in mind I'm
just on the crafting sets on G tracker
and keep in mind I did do a video on
this mal addiction word and I made 500k
in 5 minutes so if you want to see that
go ahead and check it out and you can
also do other items like The odium Shard
very similar to the malediction Ward and
you can also make lots of money on that
as well so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did give it a like I just
wanted to show you guys that it's super
easy to make money in RuneScape all you
have to do is just create items and you
can sell them for about 100K profit more
and if you do about five items a day
that's like 500k that's super easy you
can also do the same item multiple times
if you find the margins are good anyways
guys I hope you guys like this video if
you're new to the channel go ahead and
subscribe the GE tracker link is in my
description if you want to check them
out and thanks guys for watching stay
tuned for my next video
n